Hello Internet,
Enjoying your Internetting session?
Perhaps watching this video with lots of tabs
open and full of interesting things to check
out.
The Internet is amazing and that's because
of the rules which govern how it works, an
important one of which is Net Neutrality:
treating all data equally.
But some Internet Providers want to ditch
this rule to insert themselves betwixt you
and your data as the most meddlesome middlemen
in human history -- to their benefit and our
detriment.
How?
Well think of the Internet as a series of
pipes.
Some are ocean-and-continent spanning pipes
through which vast rivers of data flow.
You don't get access to those -- they're very
expensive, and you couldn't handle it anyway.
But you do have a little pipe that connects
to the big pipes, through which you can pull
down and send out data.
Your pay your Internet provider to maintain
this pipe.
This rule means that your little pipe, cares
not what flows through it: cat videos, discussion
forums, calls or games.
Whatever you're doing, you're using the whole
pipe to do and no website gets preference
over another.
Everyone wants faster Internet, but that requires
more metaphorical pipe in the ground, the
building of which is slow and expensive.
Now you may have heard your Internet provider
on the news talking about how this rule prevents
them from building 'fast lanes' for special
kinds of data -- they want you to think they're
expanding your access to the information superhighway.
But removing this rule also gives them the
power to speedbump the existing roads and
charge more to use the 'fast' lane that was
just what you had before.
The power to preference some data over others
is the power to favor one video site over
another and to limit a tiny part of the pipe
for the video you're watching right now or
trying to anyway.
We've been through this before: and constrain
other companies in similar ways.
Take the electricity.
You pay for a certain amount and when it arrives
in your house you can do with it what you
wish.
The electricity company doesn't get to decide
that rather than build more power plants it's
going to dim your bulbs and then offer a 'brighter
bulbs' monthly subscription.
And so it should go with the Internet.
Watts are watts and bits are bits and we'll
always need more and more.
And preserving this rule for the Internet
has much wider impact than just if some company
takes more of your coins.
Not to be overly dramatic here, but preserving
data equality may be one of the most important
issues in a generation.
Because without this rule Internet providers
could cripple competitors they don't like.
Ever notice the same company that sells you
internet also sells Cable TV and Landlines
-- stuff The Internet totally replaces?
Without data equality your Internet Provider
could narrow the pipe for competitors until
they either go out of business, pay the meddlesome
middleman, or both.
It's like if one store in town super-promised
to pay for fast roads everywhere as long as
the town gave them absolute power over all
the roads no backsies.
If you agree to that deal don't be surprised
when years later all traffic to them is fast
and free while the roads elsewhere are slow
and neglected.
This town is basically the Internet without
net neutrality which some Internet Providers
would love, but actual Internet citizens,
not so much.
Having the pipes treat all data the same lets
one guy with a good idea and a bit of programming
knowledge make something today that's seen
by millions tomorrow.
But only because his data is treated equally
with everything else in the pipes.
An Internet that treats data equally is an
internet that continues to shower us with
wonder.
But an Internet where middlemen pick and choose
what comes through the pipe is an Internet
of stagnation for all and profit for few.
Which is why some Internet providers will
always want that control, so the cost of preserving
our awesome Internet is eternal vigilance
on the part of good citizens to defend Net
Neutrality.